[Applause]
moments after salman rushdie is attacked
confusion and cries of horror
from a crowd who'd come to hear him
lecture but instead watched him being
stabbed
uh short all in black he ran out
and he
approached mr rushdie and for a second
it was kind of very quick so we thought
he was fixing his microphone and then we
saw the knife and he started stabbing
him in the neck first and then
in this area
and um mr rushdie
got up and started running and then the
amphitheater goes nuts people are
screaming
we can see him like stabbing there are
people in the front who got up on the
stage and grabbed the man and pulled him
off of rusty
and that took a little bit of doing
more than 20 people from the audience
are said to have fought to overpower the
attacker a man was seen later being led
from the stage
others try and give the writer first aid
as he lies on the ground
sometime later the salman rushdie is
transferred by stretcher slowly and
steadily to a helicopter medyvacs to
hospital
there he was filmed being rushed into
the building his condition is unknown
but new york's governor kathy hokel says
he is alive
i want to commend the state police it
was a state police officer who stood up
and saved his life protected him
as well as the monitor the uh the
moderator who was attacked as well
sasaman rusty was propelled to global
infamy in 1988 his novel satanic verses
provoked a furious response among some
muslims for its irreverent depiction of
the prophet muhammad his books were
banned and burned and a fatwa or death
sentence was issued by the leader of
iran ayatollah khamenei
rushdie was forced into hiding for more
than a decade
salman rushdie is one of our greatest
writers and to hear of this
terrible uh assault on him is is is
saddened uh military community and all
right thinking people everywhere
iran never lifted the fatwa but said it
wouldn't support or hinder the writer's
killing in 1998 susan rushdie was able
to live a more and more normal life but
never completely escaped the shadow
imposed on him by political islam
he's always had to live with the threat
of the kind of attack that has finally
happened